I had a great time too and by the way
this was my first year of life on so I'm
going to talk about daughter and
daughter and my son and daughter is a
popular way to package and run
applications however when you're
packaging Python applications in docker
there are some caveats so I'm going to
share with you my lessons learned when I
was trying to optimize docker builds now
I hope you will find something useful
something valuable something that you
can take away and apply in your
environment my name is Dmitry and I'm a
system engineer Cisco I create Python
applications for internal use and I
focus mostly on network automation you
can find slides here if you'd like to
follow along now before we we percieve
let's do a quick show of hands who has
been using docker already Wow ok keep
your hand raised if you are using
kweissen and docker together ok um it's
the same amount that's awesome ok so in
this talk I'm not going to talk to you
about why docker and what are the
benefits and if you should use it if you
haven't already you should check it
check it out I started using it around 2
years ago and it completely changed the
way I deploy it application so to make
sure that everyone is on the same page
let's start with some darker terminology
okay so first container it's a
lightweight way to package your
application with dependencies and
different containers have some isolation
they have separate user space but they
share the kernel of the host now next
one is docker image so docker image is a
template to create docker containers
it's built using the docker file and it
consists of read-only layers we are
going to talk about layers slate
we can upload the image to the registry
and share it with others
now docker file is a set of instructions
to build an image you start with the
base image from which one you are going
to inherit and then every instruction
does something and it creates a new
layer which is cached for future builds
so in this case I'm I have very silly
example where I inherit from Debian
image I copy a file from my host system
to the image then I run some command a
command inside of this image and then I
say that ok my default command when I'm
going to start this container is going
to be dead ok so what is docker
container its container created from
docker image we add a writable a layer
on top we allocate resources and then we
when we start the container we execute
entry point and CMD commands ok and the
last one is registry it's a place where
we store and share tagged images ok so
here is the very simple diagram again
just to summarize we have a docker file
we use docker build commands to build an
image from it we can change the attack
using docker tag we can we can push and
pull this image to the registry and when
we want to run a container we do docker
run on the image stack we apply entry
point and CMD and here we go we have a
container now in this talk we are going
to focus mostly on the left part on the
build process ok so python and docker so
on the left hand side you can see my
sample project so i have my my project
is a directory which contains which is
the python module and then i have my n
py which i run when i
want to run this application and it
didn't work some function from my
project grid details of the Python
itself here are not really important the
structure is more important now another
thing that I have is the requirements
txt file which contains Python
dependencies in this case I have only
two requests in cryptography and you
will understand why I chose something
like cryptography for for this talk now
in in the middle you can see a sample
docker file where I inherit from Python
37 image I create a directory called app
and then I copy everything from the host
system from the current directory to the
image I install my dependencies and then
I define that I'm going to run Python
main pure now it's so good it's very
simple however the size of this
container is around one gigabyte and
this talk is going in this talk we are
going to see how we can improve on that
so before we go further let's define our
optimization objective so what we are
going to optimize and there are two
things image size but also the build
time and it can be initial build time as
well as subsequent build time now let's
also define priorities and those are the
ones that I defined for myself for my
projects during development I would like
to have fast builds okay I care less
about image size during development
because whenever I change my code I'd
like to see result much faster but for
production I prefer small image size in
your case the priorities could be
different okay so the first and the most
important one is selecting the base
image so here is the comparison table I
have Python 3 7 which corresponds to
talk Python 3 7 stretch where the base
image for that is Debian stretch the
size of it is around 900 max we have
slim stretch
which is much smaller version of but
it's still using Debian ons back on the
base image it's 150 max you can see it's
six time difference already we also have
Alpine and Alpine is very popular Alpine
Linux is very popular base image
especially in container world because of
the of these small image size you can
see so much twice less than slim stretch
now what are the differences in terms of
the Python applications and these base
images well the debian uses G Lipsy and
what it allows it to do is it supports
many Linux wheels now when we are
talking about many Linux wheels we have
to talk briefly about vital native
extensions so Python native fixed
extensions we usually have to compile
them to make them work with Python and
those are libraries that some of you may
know like quick cryptography XML
Giavanna and some others they use Python
native extensions however there was this
way of creating a many Linux wheel where
we're that we don't have to compile it
it's precompiled for us we just download
the real and extract it however the
Alpine uses muscle and it doesn't
support many Linux wheels so the
consequence of that is that Python
extensions should be compiled and if you
have ever tried installing something
like Alex ml in Alpine it takes around
15 minutes just for that one dependency
now if you want to know more about many
Linux wheels and Python native
extensions there was amazing talks this
year at PyCon us the black magic of
Python wheels I strongly recommend you
watching them now also what I notice is
then in Alpine some of the well known
packages they take much less space for
example for get I think there was three
times difference in size so in general
the footprint of Alpine images is my
smore so here is my recommendation when
you care about the build time I would
select slim stretches base whenever you
care about image size I would recommend
selecting Alpine as a base the main
reason why that for a slim stretch you
can use you can use the menu Linux
wheels okay so let's let's do that so I
changed my previous docker file and now
I'm using slim stretch you can see the
Desai's from one gig is around 200 X 200
X now excuse me
this Alpine is not so simple anymore
remember we have that cryptography
dependency and it needs to be compiled
to be able to run Python
because there is no manual Linux well
there is no avail for alpine for
cryptography so this case I have to
install tools like GCC but also some
packages with the headers like open SSL
dev and when I do all of that you can
see the DES size is 300 max which is
actually bigger than slim stretch so you
may wonder like you just told us that
you should use alpha and if you care
about image size right so what's going
on here well let's first define the
problem so the problem is that the build
dependencies which are contributing to
image size here are needed only for
compilation but not the runtime this is
the main issue here so the general
solution to this is you have to include
only files necessary for your runtime in
your image so how to achieve that well
first let's take a look on when we
copying the source code to the image so
recommendation here is that to use more
specific copy statements instead of
broad copy dot dot
and you can also use docker ignore file
to ignore some of the files when you are
doing that coffee so here is the example
of docker ignore file I use I just copy
it from every you know from every
project so something like dr. Pike ash
or pyc files or vnf directory I usually
ignore that to make sure that it's never
in my in my image ok so let's apply the
technique of instead of having the broad
statement copy copy copy dot dot and
convert it to more specific copy
statements in this case i copy my my
module my python module my project and
main py so you can see that the size
decreased the reason why that I had V F
on my host and it previously got copied
to the to the image so now now it's not
there and the same is all fine we also
get around to how 20 20 max from doing
that ok now this next one is very
important removing unnecessary files and
it's not as easy as it may sound so
let's try using that Alpine docker file
it's exactly the same however I added at
the very end
additional run instruction where I'm
trying to delete GCC OpenSSL def and
some other packages because I don't need
them during the run time and if you do
that you can see that the size of the
image hasn't changed at all right so
what's going on here well to answer this
question we have to understand how
docker layers work so every instruction
create read only layer and then the new
layer can be smaller than the previous
layer those layer are cached and can be
reused for subsequent builds and layers
themselves introduce some overhead but
these two the first two are the most
important ones
so again the new layer can have it can't
have smaller size in the previous layer
so what's the consequence of this what
what is the takeaway here first is
combining multiple run statements into a
single one so that they are formed the
same layer if you need to delete files
you have to make sure that you delete
them in the same layer where they were
added because if you do it later it has
no effect whatsoever on the image size
if you want benefit from caching you
have to arrange your statements in the
order from the list changing to the most
changing usually the order will be
system level dependencies and tools
Python dependencies and then the source
code and another tip would be not to
save anything to cache for example with
people you can use no cached year not to
not to save bills this apk you can use
no cash option as well
so let's try to apply these principles
to our to our problem here now in this
case from for a slim stretch the only
thing I added was no cached year so I
got additional formats and in case of
Alpine I defined my build dependencies
and runtime dependencies and then I
combined all of my run statements into a
single one so I have I have first I
install my build dependencies then I
install my Python dependencies then I
delete build dependencies and then I
install runtime dependencies and all of
that is in a single run statement and
the result you can see it's already
three times smaller so it's 100 max now
from this point on I'm not low I will no
longer consider consider slim stretch
anymore because vo can already see the
image size of the Alpine is much smaller
smaller so we are going to continue
optimize that
but since Thresh is already is already
good so because I personally use slim
stretch for my local development builds
I don't care about those 20 30 extra max
but in case of my production image size
sometimes I do so you'll keep keep
decreasing than that size so here is an
optional thing that you can do you can
delete your pyc files and tests from
your dependencies if you want to if you
do then it became it becomes even more
complex so you have to find those files
in your user local pyc files test files
and delete them in this case you get
additional 10 max sometimes you get like
around 30 max from it really depends ok
what are the disadvantages of this
approach that I just shown well the
dockerfile become becomes really complex
you have to always remember that you
have to you have to install build
dependencies and then install everything
else that you need and then delete
everything that you don't need
everything in this single statement the
consequence of this is not only it's
complex but also you can no longer
benefit from caching you can't catch
your build dependencies in this case and
you will have to always rebuild the
container okay so dr. multistage so the
idea behind docker multistage is you
built an intermediary image where you
have all of your build dependencies and
you install your application then you
copy result for example binary if it's
go length for example or whatever it
dissolved from your programming language
is to a fresh image and then you label
it as your final final image so you have
this to separate to separate you
images if you will in one in one you
might should do all of your build
process and the second one you actually
package your application for future use
so why would you want to do them the
resulting image image size is smaller
because you will have no build
dependencies it could be also faster
because you can cache all those build
dependencies now you no longer have to
delete them anywhere
okay so however python is interpreter
interpreted language and the question is
are multistage builds relevant to Python
apps
my answer is somewhat the the main thing
is that even though Python is Python is
interpreted you still may have those
dependencies which use native Python
extensions not only that but you may
also have some other tooling that you
need as part of your build for example I
am a big fan of of tool called poetry
which allows you to manage Python
dependencies if you think about that in
people and fees also in the same league
if you think about that you only need
the tool to install your dependencies
from the log file but you don't really
need that tool to run your app so all of
that can really go to that build stage
and then you can copy only your result
to your final image okay so here is the
idea
and thanks to henyk for sharing it on
Twitter in order to simplify copying
from one stage to another the easy
solution would be to use virtual
environments so the idea that you have
your code of your application you create
a virtual environment in the same folder
for example you install dependencies
that you need and then between the build
stage and your
well final stage you just change you
just copy the whole project directory
including your source code including
your virtual environment and it works
out pretty well so let's take a look so
this is the example of python docker
multi-stage it may seem a little bit
complex but it really isn't from our
previous examples on the left hand side
I have my builder stage where I still
have my build dependencies I install
them I create virtual environment and
then I also upgrade people in that case
I copy my requirement stick C and then I
install my dependencies and then in this
case I also delete pyc files and tests
but you don't really have to do that
stage and then on the right hand side so
the result from the left-hand side that
in slash up slash dot V and V we have
our virtual environment and in slash up
slash my project we have our module so
in the second stage inherit from Python
three seven Alpine again and so my
runtime dependencies only and then i
copy my slash app directory and that's
pretty much it so you no longer have to
care about you know have to care about
how you delete those pill dependencies
the size is a little bit bigger because
you use virtual environments but I think
that's fine so one additional piece that
you get in this case your build
dependencies are now cache so everything
well depending if you change the Python
dependencies often or not you can catch
up to line 14 or maybe maybe even
further maybe even the whole build stage
it really depends because you don't have
to do it anything so in case you don't
change your Python dependencies you
catch the whole layer in case you change
them but your system level build
dependencies are still the same you can
cache up until a line 12 so that's
pretty nice because previously we could
we couldn't do caching at all okay so
now that we have that you can also
create your custom image with common
build dependencies across your multiple
projects for example as I told you I
like using poetry in some cases I need
curl to download something sometimes I
need it get I may also need you know a
bunch of build dependencies so I just
built a custom image for it and I store
it in a registry so then that
multi-stage is simplified even further
we just have to inherit from your custom
image and everything else is the same
okay a couple of quick advices here or
suggestions what I found for my local
dev where I use slim stretch sometimes
by binding Mau of don't find mount of
your source code instead of copy it
really pays off especially if you have
web app with some reload capability so
that's pretty nice so you just have to
change the code and you don't have to
rebuild the container really depends but
it may be useful for you now another one
is aging the environmental variables
Python and buffered so everything is
printed to the STD out ease of buffering
and then don't write byte code one if
you don't want to generate PYC files
which i think it's not really needed in
your talker image okay now this is my
example I'm not going to go into details
you can download slides later where I'm
using poetry so it's a little bit
complicated to build if you're
interested in that you can check out
check it out from the slides so let's do
a summary so first and foremost you have
to select the base image carefully so
Alpine for smaller
sighs slim stretch when you need faster
pills you have to take into account
layer caching so combine different
statements into one if you want to
delete something you have to make sure
you delete it in the same statement
where you added that you have to order
statements from the list most changing
to benefit from caching and then the
last one
dr. multi-stage can help can help you
avoid some complex removal procedures
and benefit from the caching and if you
go down this path I recommend using
Python virtual environment it's really
nice in this case even though I am not
really in favor of using virtual
environment in docker container and
that's all I have for you today
thank you very much
Thank You Dmitry we have a few minutes
for means for questions one two three
okay I thank you for this great talk I
have at this very simple question have
you evaluated like using other base
images like clearly nooks or min depth
because they both have to deep sea and
may be much smaller than stretch last
name thank you for the question I
haven't now that you mentioned I
probably should check it out yeah you
should really check it out
thank you
if you write unit tests how do you run
them okay that's amazing question it
really depends in my case I built a
development docker container for that
and I run that so it's not the same as
my production container so yeah I just
have a separate container to to run that
and I include my development
dependencies there and I run them there
all right thanks thank you
any more questions
then I'll go ahead and ask what question
do you think if we in the the build
stage if you instead of like installing
a virtual evident in the second stage
you would actually build the wheels and
then use those wheels to install the
second stage I think we think that would
like lower the size of that or I have
you tried using this technique instead
of building the virtual earth I haven't
tried it even though it was one of the
suggestions and one of the things that I
wanted to explore I don't have a data to
confirm it but I don't really see any
benefit from doing that but it is just
my personal opinion and so because when
we saw here by adding a virtual
environment I just added five max to the
container it was acceptable for my case
okay thank you for your talk
and just for a curiosity how does your
local development environment look like
what kind of tools do you use and to use
docker when you're developing so i well
my local development is my Mac and I use
docker sometimes they use docker
sometimes I don't
so it really depends like how complex
the application is if there are a lot of
outside of Python things you know for
example if you swept up you know some
database your front-end and stuff like
that then I do use docker and to make
sure that everything is is working and I
would like you know to see and touch the
result if if I don't really you know if
it's only Python and nothing else and I
usually don't use docker locally but
most of the time I do so and editing
onto that I do use tools like poetry to
manage dependencies and I think that's
pretty much it I think we have time for
one more question also concerning
testing you said you have another
environment for local development you
also used for testing but what about
integration tests do you run them like
in that same container or is it like I
would be a bit bit afraid of running
that in a completely different container
than production so there are different
approaches for stuff I do I actually do
it in a separate container but that's
just me I don't have well according to
my requirements that's okay however I do
understand your concern that yeah it may
it may make sense to if you have your
integration tests to run it on your
production container thank you
unfortunately we don't have time for any
more questions you can find it meet you
around the conference thank you thank
you